I'll start by selecting the navList by passing in the class .nav-list.
Then I want the first item in the navList, so
I use children to get the children of navList, and
then I use the .first method to make sure I've got the first one.
After that, I want the link in the first one, so I find the a tag inside of it.
At that point, it's pretty simple.
I use the the .attr method to change the href attribute and set it to number 1.
After hitting Test Run, I can see that item number 1 now has a link attached to
it, which is pretty cool.
Let's just make sure it's the right one.
I'll open up Dev Tools by inspecting this element.
And we can see that yes, this a tag has a href of number 1.